okay
good morning uh time being nine o'clock
and we have
um enough membership here I'd like to
welcome all of you to the home of Public
Works and highways
um I'm the chair Mark McConkey
we are going to start this morning with
the capital budget overview committee
and part of our organization is that we
will
welcome
we will uh we will move into uh
nominations
of chairman
Vice chairman and Clerk and with that I
will open up the nomination process and
recognize representative Cloutier okay
thank you Mr Hackney chairman uh I
nominate representative McConkey to be
chair of capital budget overview
the
McConkey has been nominated as chair uh
and seconded are the further nominations
seeing none
um all those in favor signify by saying
aye
aye opposed
we will now open up for uh Vice chairman
and I will recognize Senator Lang I
nominate Senator waters for vice chair
thank you Senator Waters has been
nominated in second are there others
wishing to
seeing none uh excuse Mr chair who's
back into the nomination of Senator
Waters please I'm back okay thank you
very much appreciate it
so motion has been made and seconded all
those in favor signify by saying aye aye
um I would like to nominate now for
clerk representative Cloutier
second and second by Boyd
you okay with that John
are there any uh further nominations for
Clark
seeing none if you're in favor of uh Mr
Cloutier as represent Cloutier is being
clerk signified by saying aye aye
those opposed
passes unanimously
thank you we now have
the committee uh named at this time
I'd like to move to
um
to ask if
item two
uh Chris Shea is there is there anything
that we else we need to know before we
go into uh
23002 at this time
2302 is just a compilation of the
various rsas that the capital budget
overview committee may experience
through their work so it was just a
One-Stop shop for the committee is all
it was so if there's any questions of me
I can certainly try to answer them but
it was just a way to give the committee
a sense of the types of uh requests that
might come to you thank you appreciate
that move on to item number three the
acceptance of minutes of November 28th
uh 2022 meeting
I know they were in your package are
there any um
is there a motion to accept some more
desperate to
uh Lloyd uh
and second by gray okay
yeah are there any questions on the
minutes Corrections omissions
all those in favor of the minutes uh as
printed for November 28 2022 signified
by saying aye aye
I'll abstain Mr chair since I was thank
you well too abstaining
okay
old business item number four we have
none
um I'd like to move to uh new business
um
um 23003
uh P's Development Authority division of
ports and harbors request authorization
to expend 82 000 969 30 cents from the
harbor dredging of peer maintenance fund
the approval of the PDA Board of
Directors for the purposes of completing
necessary repairs to the fuel dispensing
system on the recreational Dock at the
Rye Harbor Beach Marine facility has
signified in the request stated uh
February 17 2023
is there someone here to speak for
I believe Geno had already told us ahead
of time he wasn't able to make it so
welcome
and please fill us in on your request
good morning Mr chair
my name is Wood Anderson I'm the
operations manager for the port
authority
this project is to replace the
recreational fuel system at our Rye
Harbor facility
currently the system is um is not in
code it's also taken some damage from
some of the High
um could I bring you a little oh sure
bring it a little closer to the
microphone yep is that better okay here
we go
um the system has also taken some um
some damage from the couple of the last
storms we've had
um so it's it's due for an upgrade a
couple of the things that we are going
to do with the new system is bring the
fuel terminal itself up above the fuel
deck currently the sump under um
underneath the fuel dispenser sits below
the deck which with the high water
causes damage and issues so that will be
raised the fuels reels will be raised
and uh there'll be some higher strength
piping as well as a
a higher strength sump that'll be
installed as well
thank you you're welcome
are there questions of the committee
members
seeing none uh pleasure of the committee
move approval Mr chairman
who's second at emotionally I'm sorry
thank you very much Senator Wayne
motion's been made and seconded uh for
the approval of 23003
any further discussion
good morning
seeing seeing none if you're in favor of
the motion signified by saying aye aye
those opposed
unanimous
while you're here I'd like to move on to
item
23004 peace Development Authority
division of ports and harbors requests
authorization to expend 13
781 dollars from the harbor dredge and
peer maintenance fund with the approval
of the PDA Board of Directors for the
purpose of completing
specifications and design plans for a
fuel
enclosure on the recreational Dock at
the Rye Harbor Marine facility as
specified in the request stated uh
February 17 2023.
please
yes Mr chair so this is for the
enclosure to go over the fuel dispensing
system a couple years ago we replaced
the fuel system at the Portsmouth
commercial fish Pier on Pierce Island
Road in Portsmouth it will be the same
style a three-sided building to keep the
system out of the weather out of the
environment protected well of lighting
and uh as well as some outlets and other
features for
um our customers to use
um so it's just a basic structure to
keep the uh the fuel system out of the
weather in the elements
thank you
any questions yes representative thank
you Mr chairman and thank you
um
I know this is for this purpose but
since it is planning at this site uh is
are you beginning to look into it all
the capacity for hydrogen Marine fueling
station at this location I know there's
some interest in Newington and
um you know given that that is a way
that some of this industry is beginning
to go
uh is there I mean is this something you
think you should look at in the future
maybe study
uh yes sir absolutely
um it's uh something that has been
brought up
um I do not have all the knowledge to
speak of it and a lot of the information
I know director Mark Coney and assistant
director um Nichols have had that
discussion and uh if you would like I
can get some information and get back to
you with that
if I may follow up yes please follow I
guess you know I I obviously I Dr Gino
but would you bring back just the
question
um as to whether they would whether
within your existing budgets you have
funds to do a study or whether you need
a legislative act to
direct to study and provide some money
for it so just if you could ask about
you know what you think you're going to
need in the future in that area
so that's something you'd like me to
pass along and ask director Marconi and
assistant director Nichols okay very
well
thank you sir
any further questions
seeing none pleasure of the committee
uh
Boyd moves Lang second thank you
um further discussion seeing none if
you're in favor of the uh
23004 signified by saying aye aye those
opposed
motion carries
thank you
next item is
23007 the University system in New
Hampshire request capital budget
overview committee approval of a project
intended to be financed by the
university system of New Hampshire
through any and all transaction relating
to the issuance in sale and delivery of
the New Hampshire health education
facilities Authority n h e f a s of the
New Hampshire system
of its University system in New
Hampshire issue
please if you had come forward
it seems like we were just doing this a
few days ago
well the the info we have an
informational item that's very
repetitive of what house Public Works
heard on Monday good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is
Catherine provencher I serve as the
chief administrative officer and vice
Chancellor of Finance for our state's
University system Bill Janelle is the
associate vice president of facilities
and planning at the University of New
Hampshire this item on your agenda the
Hetzel Hall project has been approved by
our Board of Trustees to be funded with
bonds
and does we issue the university system
issues its debt through FIFA the health
and education facilities Authority that
enabling legislation for FIFA requires
that those Bond funded projects be
approved by this committee
that's why we're in front of you this
morning the university system has not
issued new money bonds since 2016. we
rarely issue debt this project though
um and Bill will talk about the project
itself in just a minute this project We
Believe has
absolute capacity to fund The Debt
Service and will also result in
additional net operating revenues over
the life the prod the petzl hall has
been shuttered
three years three years
um it needs quite a bit of deferred
maintenance it needs a lot of upkeep so
it's been shuttered by the university
for the past three years it's an iconic
building it's right in the heart
um of campus in Durham and so the the
plan is to completely overhaul the
layout of the building to remove the
traditional
dorms like I had when I was in college
and moved toward a
a layout that students prefer now we are
over subscribed on in our housing now at
UNH because covid's over students are
back and we are very confident that
we'll be able to to fill these beds so
if you'd like Bill can walk through the
specifics of the project and so I will
and you have in your material there's a
deck if you will with pictures and
schematics and the return on investment
calculations and the like
thank you Kathy uh good morning good
morning representative McConkey members
of the capital budget overview committee
uh so yeah Hetzel Hall
um as Kathy said it's one of our iconic
residence Halls it's on Main Street it's
right in the middle of Durham it's
currently uh not occupied it was built
in 1925 so it's about 100 years old
um currently has about 154 beds
and we're proposing a complete gut
renovation of that building
including envelope improvements
mechanical systems and as Kathy said
we're looking to reconfigure the
interior layout as well when we're done
we're targeting about 140 beds and
looking at what we call a semi-sweet
configuration project costs are about 29
million all in and we're looking at a
design build delivery method starting we
we selected the contractor and have
somewhat started already and we're
looking for occupancy at the summer of
2024.
so existing conditions it hasn't seen a
lot of
comprehensive renovation since it was
built
um it's currently vacant as Kathy said
during the pandemic we saw the need drop
for housing on campus and this was is
one of our oldest buildings and in the
toughest shape we've got mold issues
other issues within the building so we
decided not to occupy it we still spend
about 135 000 a year just to heat it
maintain it all of those things there's
significant deferred maintenance in the
project we anticipate this will address
about 13.6 million in deferred
maintenance and when the Project's done
we see it generating about 1.9 million
per year in revenue from housing and
dining we see the project will will
increase retention of our students
increase graduation and overall
satisfaction with the housing experience
at unh
so on the next slide on on page three
this kind of describes what what we're
trying to do here in Hetzel in changing
the configuration so what we have right
now are many
um
double rooms on what we would call
Double loaded corridors so same room on
each side and they they access a single
bathroom say on a floor we have many of
those on campus what we'd like to do is
change the variety in an Ideal World we
would this is the progression that you
see on
um slide three where you might first
your student might start in that type of
a double room but then they would move
into more of a semi-sweet
configuration and then variations of
singles and triples and then eventually
into an apartment style unit we don't by
no means do we have that on campus some
of our competitors have more of those
we're just looking to increase
um that semi-sweet style offering so
that's what we're hoping to gain out of
this project
the budget
construction costs about 29.1 uh sorry
21.1 million with additional soft costs
loaded in there with subtotal of 26.4
million and we're holding a bid
contingency of 2.6 million for a total
budget of 29. million 29 million dollars
sorry for the total project cost
on Sly on Slide Five
we've got some financial information
um so on the left hand side here just
shows the progression of the project
has positive return
um right off as soon as it's occupied we
show a 20-year payback for the project
again it's looking at a 100 Year
construction life which is kind of what
we're looking at now so we see
significant return in the future here
um
and again addressing about 13.6 million
dollars in deferred maintenance and we
show a quick return of at least 1.9
million
per year in incremental revenue for the
project
what's shown in the left hand corner of
this slide is just a sense of some of
the other residence Halls that we have
in line that need work as well
Hetzel is at the top of the list but
there's also Babcock Stoke Williamson
Christensen many of these Halls that
were built you know mid 60s that also
need attention in the future
and then the last slide essentially just
shows the schedule again like I
previously mentioned started in the fall
of last year and we're looking for
completion in July of uh 24 for
occupancy that fall
thank you questions the university Mr
chairman if I might um so folks no I do
work at the University of New Hampshire
um none of the things we're discussing
today will benefit me or my department
directly I will be participating and
voting thank you thank you for that uh
representative include here okay thank
you thank you Mr chairman could you tell
me when was herzl because I can't seem
to find her you mentioned about the 60s
when was it built so as far as we
determine exact age it's built in 1925.
oh oh 19 I'm sorry 1925 thank you 100
years old
yes I'm sorry senator please thank you
Mr was there somebody else first or no
go right ahead thank you
um
so I'm looking at uh your um
credit opinion
and um it seems to me that this would be
really rather negligible in terms of the
overall ratios
um yes and we met with Moody's in the
fall for our annual
um surveillance they call it and our
board had already had a first look at
this project and we shared with Moody's
that the Investments that we were
thinking about potential bonding in the
future that was all included in the
conversation and Moody's still improved
our Outlook from negative to stable and
I will add two weeks later put the
entire higher ed industry on negative
outlook after increasing hours from
negative to stable
um
so um what in terms of Energy Efficiency
what standard are you going to meet in
the building
uh typically we shoot for a lead silver
for the project
from an Energy Efficiency standpoint
from a lead standard we don't actually
do the documentation for for the lead
standard but that's the the level that
we shoot for but we are looking at
insulating as part of the project as
part of the envelope improvements new
roof new windows as well
if I made one more so um I I just
wondering how you're kind of
conceptualizing and you're planning on
this and the other dorms in the future
whether you're thinking about any Net
Zero attempts
um in terms of your energy supplies and
insulation and you know just the kinds
of things people are doing to get a
higher standard than the one you've just
outlined yeah I mean we're looking at
that across campus as well I mean this
building is served with from our
district heating system on campus that's
this comes from our co-generation
facility
um
so yeah we're looking at all those
options and we have we plan to do a
decarbonization study as part of our
master plan process that's upcoming soon
to take a look at at you know what's the
road map that we how we get there to Net
Zero in the future
um
it involves heat but also involves
energy generation as you I'm sure you
know right now we we generate our energy
of landfill gas 100 of our energy comes
from the the landfill
um
and
you know whether we go with heat pumps
in the future at our buildings or
whether we look at some other fuel at
the cogeneration facility that's all
things that we need to look at as part
of that decarbonation decarbonization
plans yes thank you thank you Senator
Lang please move to approve cap I lost
the number
23007 for the University of New
Hampshire
Senator Lang moves seconded by
I'm sorry representative
any further questions
yes yes represent boy
thank you let's try to quickly get
through the credit opinion but what is
usm's current debt all religions
if you go to
it's uh page 17 I provided a debt
overview
no no problem I provided a debt overview
our Total Bonds outstanding are 331
million and you'll see that bar chart on
how the progression of The Debt Service
gets paid down I'll also mention that as
part of this new money should it be
approved this new money bond issue we're
looking to refinance those what we call
synthetic fixed those variable rate
bonds
um and so our total bond issue would be
closer to a hundred million right those
are we refund those bonds and get out of
those variable rates
um we've worked with our financial
advisors we think that could provide a
small Financial benefit to the
university system also when we refinance
those bonds we will not extend the
maturity dates we will refinance those
bonds fixed rate to mature at the same
time we're not going to go out another
30 years so
Mr chairman I'm sorry yes I'm sorry
follow-up thank you
can you explain to me
so synthetic we have variable rate bonds
there the actual bonds here are variable
rate they were issued back in 2005 and
2011 before my time
then what what happened what then what
they do is they have these variable rate
bonds but they
wrap what's called a swap around those
bonds so they behave like they're fixed
rate
believe you me if I could have refunded
those bonds
three four years ago look at the effects
of all-in rates are four three and a
half and almost five if I could have
refunded those bonds when rates were
down at two we would have done that but
because there it has this synthetic swap
wrapped around that variable rate they
trade weekly
I couldn't get out of it now that rates
are starting to go up I can get out of
these we can reduce the risk there's
risk involved in having these variable
rate bonds we can reduce the risk and
maybe get a small pickup for the
University system with with um with some
of the rates we're modeling right now
four to four and a quarter
on a fixed 30 rate 30-year rate but
again these aren't going to be 30 or
we're going to keep these maturities
10 years 12 years so that's what a
synthetic fix is it behaves like a fixed
because of this swap but it's not really
a fixed
briefly we're running time
what is your time friends May
I think that the clerk is trying to tell
you that you need to turn your mics on
yeah I apologize thank you thank you sir
thank you Mr chairman
um the as I understand it the
um
the revenue well the dining the dining
operation and the housing operations are
sort of separate sit on their own
bottoms is that correct oh yeah so so
the funds that will pay off this debt
come not from tuition but rather from
housing correct absolutely thank you
thank you senator for the question a
couple important points none of these
bonds are guaranteed by the state
whatsoever
the university system does not have
authority to issue debt for General
obligation from tuition and fees it has
authority to issue debt that will be
paid back solely by what we call
auxiliary Revenue
self-funded structures and so this will
be these bonds will be paid back by room
fees if you will so there would be no
impact on tuition at all correct okay
thank you
motion has been made and seconded for
item number
23007 for the University system of New
Hampshire
if you're in favor of that motion
signify it by saying aye
aye any opposed
motion passes unanimously
thank you very much thank you
the um
we have some informational items listed
here at the end that are contained in
your packets
item zero one zero five zero six and
zero eight is
oh I'm sorry I'll wait unless there's a
question from the committee okay are
there anyone wishing to discuss those
items at this time
represent McConkey and the rest of the
committee I just want to point out that
item 23006 which is a an item it's an
informational item from the Department
of administrative Services it has to do
with a capital project that was
appropriated to the Department of
administrative services and that
building which is Phil Brook building is
now housing
for HHS clients or customers and the
department wanted to raise the question
of should we change who's controlling
that appropriation this is something
that would probably should be taken up
in the capital budget so I just wanted
to bring that forward since we have a
mix of senators and house members that
will be dealing with the capital budget
going forward okay
thank you an administrative Services
here if there's any specific questions
does anyone have any questions
administrative services
thank you
the last item here is uh setting a date
for the next meeting
um for the new members it's typically on
a quarterly fashion unless some item
comes up in an emergency that we need to
meet earlier I'm going to suggest at
this time that we meet on May 26 with
the same times and I believe that's a
Friday
so unless uh Senators have an issue with
the day please get back to us and uh
Senator gray the only question is that
late in the month whether it interferes
with fiscal or rules or whatever
so and my calendar doesn't go out that
far right now for for those committees
so
that could be a problem
if I might uh chairman McConkey is uh
with fiscal you probably would be fine
because typically that meeting starts at
10 if it is on that day fiscal has
tended to be scheduled the third Friday
of the month
um except for this month
yes if I may know yes Mr chairman it is
the Friday before Memorial Day weekend
and uh okay so I'm not I'm with you Mr
chair I mean I may be out of town but I
know others if others uh sounds like a
wonderful day to have that meeting
it's all good with me if if it becomes
an issue
um we'll certainly discuss that and if
we have to move it we will all right any
any further business before this
committee
seeing none we'll call to a close this
meeting thank you